[Music]
time now for what to watch and vladimir
baby eloise had me up all weekend
one of the worst weeks we're sleeping on
the floor it was terrible
on the floor mike tyson says everyone's
got a plan to get punched in the mouth
everyone's got a plan until the baby
starts crying as well
out the window wake me up here i am
tony rise and shine everybody here a few
stories we think you'll be talking about
today
one of the richest men on earth is going
along on his aerospace company's first
trip into space
look at what jeff bezos just announced
on instagram
you see the earth from space it changes
you it changes your relationship with
this planet with humanity
it's one earth i want to go on this
flight because
it's a thing i've wanted to do all my
life
it's an adventure it's a big deal for me
i invited my brother to come on this
first flight because
we're closest friends i really want you
to come with me
would you are you serious i am i think
it would be meaningful
have my brother there i wasn't even
expecting him to say that he was going
to be
on the first flight and then when he
asked me to go along i was
just awestruck serious if you're willing
if you want to
yeah what a remarkable opportunity not
only to
have this adventure but to be able to do
it with my best friend
all about his brother's like seriously
you want me to go with you so
that's so nice yeah bezos and his
brother mark will go up
on blue origin's first human space
flight on july 20th they will join the
winner
of an auction which opened last month
the high bid has already
reached nearly 3 million dollars bidding
is open
until july 10th i wasn't so scared
go go with jeff yeah that's the guy you
want to go with
exactly so scared but i love their
interaction between he and his brother
and for jeff to say i've wanted to do it
since i was five since i was a little
boy
i think it's pretty cool you got that
2.8 million if i had
been with you if i had it sitting around
i would bid tomorrow i really would i
would
go up there it's a sub-orbital flight
which means it's called for a bit they
experience weightlessness to get an
unbelievable view
yes and then you're back and that
spaceship the the uh it's called the new
shepard has had 15 missions a little
problem some problems on the first one
but since then it's been smooth sailing
have you ever been on the concord have
any of you i was like so do you remember
like i took it once right at the early
start of my career on wall street and i
remember looking out the window and you
can actually see
the arc right and it was so cool you
were that close to space so i can see
how this i like the three hours part
i know it was nice and fast very much